curious he's still got the same living
Arrangement where um you and your ex
still live together in that Firehouse
yes he's my partner in Parenthood but
that is so you know listen that's very
unconventional I guess the state yeah
we're family and we love these kids and
we're adults so and if you and if you
bring home a date to your Firehouse well
I haven't I I'm not I'm not dating so uh
yeah not at all I have no I haven't no
no what is going on Anderson you're the
hottest guy
I got two kids who I I can't imagine not
spending every minute with and I'm
working all the time so I you know you
have needs Anderson you have needs yeah
I'm I'm I'm happy I'm happy right now
the word is that gen Z you know what gen
Z is I mean Vegas those are 20 year olds
are calling you a twunk do you know what
a twink is you have the face of a twink
but the body of a hunk I'm looking uh
muscular biceps that you're showing off
getting this very tight t-shirt I've
dropped like 20 pounds with kids like
I'm just kidding I haven't no I've just
started again I got a great trainer
named Leo who's really good so I'm
hoping to like get back to it but I'm
looking at you you're in the best shape
of your life you got big muscular arms
you look handsome yourself why you don't
have a boyfriend why are you not on a
dating app I don't understand what's
going on I'm not on a dating app no I
don't know that I would I could do that
I don't know have you had the great love
of your life yet Anderson you have not
uh this is what I'm talking about you
want me to set you up I may think who
won oh my God he's the worst when
straight people try to set gay people up
it rarely works we gotta find you
someone
you don't fantasize about a great love
affair I I got I've got a great love
affair with my kids right now so I'll
stop it that's different well that's
different it's the best thing ever
foreign